so as I said at the beginning of this
thing I absolutely loved the first
season of the boys and I know you guys
are currently filming the second season
yeah what can you it's first of all
Congrats on getting a second season
before the first season even came out
yeah
that shows how expensive the show is
yeah our whole thing with it they spend
enough money would be just half they
have to keep going yeah they're just
like we can't stop we look stupid at
this point yeah but being serious what
did you tease people about the second
season and with the success of the first
season they put out a press release
saying how popular it is do you are you
already thinking wow maybe we are gonna
go even bigger in the third yes they
yeah they already have more resources
for the second season and they are
adding more characters and they are the
scope of the show organically grows as
the show continues and we just watched
actually the first episode of the second
season this week and we were all it was
a wonderful thing as producers we were
like this is way better than I ever
could have hoped it was going to be just
like looks a bit better feels bigger the
actors all know what they're doing it's
just it was it was exciting and I think
with the show like the boys especially
where the tone is so unique like for the
actors to be able to watch the show and
to see like oh that's that's what it is
it allows them to come back with just
like completely locked into it you know